誰もがドーガンによる日本語の方言の次の公開リリースへようこそ。
私の常連客のもう一人がとても
親切に前に出て、
パトレオンの日本語の方言のアクセントのレッスンのこの紹介で、
すべての日本語学習者は本当に恩恵を受けると思います。
これを見ることができたら
、これまでの
ように他の常連客のように日本語の方言のアクセントを一般に公開
していただけませんか。
これは、
日本語の方言のアクセントの
エピソードの紹介です。 過去に
は、10分で日本の絵のようだと思います。これ
は
、そのレッスンの適切なバージョンの一種で、
超高品質のネイティブ録音が
含まれているだけでなく、4つの点に注意するのも良いです。
日本語の方言のアクセントの
パターンと、レッスンの冒頭でカバーする2つの基本的な日本語の方言の
アクセントの規則な
ので、以前の
公開リリースでは、 このように
設定された私のデスクの追加の解説が1つ
あります。これは通常、
数
年前に元のビデオを作成して以来、日本語の音声学またはその特定のトピックについて学んだことがかなりあるためです
が、このレッスンは実際
には基礎です。 私が作った元のレッスンのリメイクは、
この時点でおそらく4年前のように言いたい
ので、
おそらく1年前かそこらで作ったこのリメイクははるかに
最近であり、
スクリプト
を試してみるのに多くの時間を費やしました。
後でコメントを追加する必要がなくなると言うので、その
ままにしておき
ますが、お支払いいただきありがとう
ございます。このレッスンを
一般に公開していただき、ありがとうございます。多くの人がいると思います。
このレッスン
は、
日本語の方言のアクセントの入門書のようなもので
あり、その意味では、15〜20分のレッスンを知っ
ているのはあなただけであるにもかかわらず、このレッスンの恩恵を受けることができ
ます。
特に
、日本語の勉強を始める前にこれをよく見ると、日本語に大きな影響を与え
ます。
3、4、
5、10年のことを知っていれば、それでも確かに役立ちますが、役に立ちます
悪い習慣を身につける前にそれを見るとさらに
高低アクセントになるといいのですが、これで日本人の学習者を救うことができます。すでに日本語を学び始め
ているのなら、始めるのに遅すぎること
はありません。
高低アクセントについて何かを学ぶ前に、日本語の勉強をもっと詳しく学ぶので、
遅すぎることは
ないので、イントロにはおそらく良いと思いますが
、今からレッスンに入りましょう。
こんにちは、日本語の第6話へようこそ。
このレッスンの
高低アクセント2つの基本的な日本語のアクセントの規則と、4つの基本的な日本語の高低アクセントのアクトとパターンを紹介し
ます。
すべてのスタンドアロン単語の1番目と2番目のモーラのピッチは
常に異なる
ため、低いピッチで始まる単語は
すぐにピッチが上がり
、高いピッチで始まる単語は
すぐ
にピッチが下がります。この例をいくつか見てみましょう。
rule now
hana hana
tenki tenki
otoko
再び日本語のスタンドアロンの単語は
、2つの連続したlow
または2つの連続したhighmora
で始まること
はありません。
単語
がダウンステップまたはピッチの低下を経験すると、
ピッチはその単語内で戻ることはありません。
したがって、
許容可能なピッチ動作の観点から
、日本の
低から高へのアクションパターンは大丈夫
です。 個々の単語レベルではなく、
高低高ピッチのパターン
は日本語には存在しません。
今
、私たちだけの単語を使用して、このルールのいくつかの例を見てみましょう。 今回
は、各単語の最後にあるパーティクルをアタッチするのを見ました
が、低高低が存在することに再び注意してください。しかし、
高低高は
、
ダウンステップまたは
ピッチの低下が発生した場合、個々の単語レベルで再び大丈夫ではありませ
ん。 つまり
、個々の単語レベル
で、ダウンステップが発生すると、ピッチは低くなり
ます。これまで
の4つの基本的な
日本語の方言のアクセントパターン
を待っていたのは、
高から低、低、高、低などです。
一般的に
、日本語に存在するさまざまな高低アクセントやパターンについて話し
ますが、これ以降
は、実際の特定の
日本語の用語を使用して、それぞれ
を詳細
に分類し、または
頭の高さから始めます。 このパターンのパターン
最初のモーラという単語のピッチは高く、粒子を含む残りのすべて
のモーラのピッチ
は低いです。ここでは、アトモラカパターンメガメガ
を使用する単語のネイティブ録音をいくつか示します。
私たちが英語の単語を
アメリカが
アトムピッチアクセントパターン
を使用していると言った場合、その単語
は粒子であると偽って、
この
アメリカは
アメリカである
アメリカであると私の意見ではアトモラカは
最も簡単なピッチアクセントパターンのように聞こえます
ネイティブの英語を話す人が模倣するため
に
、英語に
は比較的高い高低アクセントで始まり、英語のよう
に再び下がる単語がたくさんあるので、
英語はストレス
アクセント言語である
ため、英語のアクセントのある音節はかなり大きくなる傾向があり
ます 英語のように周囲の音節よりも長い
ため、直接比較することは困難です。
このパターンは
、日本語と日本語の辞書の1番で示され
ます。これについては、レッスン7の
高低アクセントパターンの2番
または中程度の高さの単語で詳しく説明します。
最初のモーラのピッチは低く、2番目の
モーラの
ピッチは高く、単語のどこかで
ダウンステップ
またはピッチの低下が発生します rsパーティクルは
常に
低い例を添付し
ます。アメリカを使用する場合は
、この単語セットの2つのナカタカ発音を作成できます。1つ
は2番目のモーラのダウンステップで、
アメリカは
アメリカです。
アメリカの3番目のモーラはアメリカ
ですアメリカ
はアメリカ
は2つのナカダカ
の発音を作成したばかりです
が、
基本的にすべてのナカラカの単語は
1つの正しい高低アクセントパターンしかないため、
おにぎり
または常にこれで発音されます。 ピッチ
アクセントパターン
とこのピッチアクセントパターン
はどちらもナカダカではありません
が、単語の途中でダウンステップが発生しているため、
個々の
ナカダカの単語には、ほとんどの
場合、正しいピッチアクセントパターンが1つだけあります。
ボール
このダウンステップはほとんどすぐに発生します
が、
言い換えれば、日本人のように
このダウンステップはoccです 単語の終わりに向かって、
ネイティブの英語を話す人
は通常
、ナカラカの
パターンにそれほど問題はありません。アメリカ
など
、単語の途中で
高低アクセントがある英語の単語がたくさんあるので、英語のアクセントは
アメリカのように日本のアクセントよりも大きくて長いので、直接比較するのは難しい
です。レッスン7の高低アクセント
パターン番号3の
オダカまたはこのパターンのテールハイで、ナカダカの単語が日本語と日本の辞書でどのように示されるかを説明します。
単語
最初のモーラは低いピッチを持っています2番目の
モーラは高いピッチ
を持っており、単語内に残っているすべての道徳
は高いピッチを持っています
が、粒子は
低いピッチの
例で付着
します オラカパターンそれは
このアメリカのように聞こえるでしょうアメリカ
はアメリカです
アメリカは
アメリカです私は個人的に
オダカが最も難しいと信じています ネイティブの
英語を話す人が模倣するパターンは、
実際
には英語に似たものがないため
です。したがって、ネイティブの英語を話す人
が高低アクセントの研究を始めたばかりの場合は、このレッスン
の前の
ネイティブの
録音セクション
をodakaで見ることを強くお勧めします。
少なくとも数週間、または中高パターンのような高低アクセント
を実際に内面化し始めていると感じるまで、1日に複数回繰り返さ
れる
単語レッスン7では、高低アクセントの単語が日本語から
日本語の辞書
でどのように示されるかを説明します。 これにより
、最終的な高低アクセントパターン
またはこのパターンのフラットスラッシュモノトーンが残り
ます。最初のモーラという単語のピッチは低く
、単語内の残りのすべてのモーラと
次の粒子の
ピッチは高く
、 この
ような
標準的なバイナリペイチェックとグラフィックスは
非常に劇的に見える可能性がありますが、単語は通常非常に
穏やかです。 エピソード6.3
でこのシリーズのバイナリピッチアクショングラフィックスを使用している
理由今のところ、ヘボン語のピッチの最初の上昇
は
通常それほど
劇的
ではなく、この単語のため
に実際の日常のピッチの変化はほとんどないことを知っています
スピーチ
これはもちろん、彼らがアメリカと呼ばれる理由です。
私たちのアメリカが爆弾パターンで設定された単語であると言えば、
この
アメリカは
アメリカです
干し草の爆弾パターンは
ネイティブの英語を話す人にとってしばしば難しいです ある種のアクセントのある
単語に慣れているので、最初は模倣します
が、ほとんどの人
は、このパターンが非常に単調であることに気付いた後、このパターンに目覚め
ます。 ゼロで日本語から
日本語への辞書で示されている
ので
、この時点で
、多くの高低アクセントリソースがグループ化するためにkifkushkiという用語を使用していることを言及する価値があるかもしれません
自動車
のパターンをダウンステップグループのパターンに変換します
が、この用語についてはまだ心配する必要はないので
、
4つの日本の高低アクセントとパターンの基本的な
理解ができたので、次の
高低アクセントは次の4つであることがわかりました。
日本語の高低アクセントパターンは日本語
に存在します。時間の経過とともに積極的に高低アクセントを聞き始める必要があり
ます。
この積極的な高低アクセントのプロセス
により、これらの各パターンを自然な方法で識別し、模倣する能力が発達し
ます。4つの日本語の高低
アクセントパターンは、
アタマラカまたは
このエピソードのすべての高低
アクセント 日本語の方言の
アクセントについて誰かに日本語の方言のアクセントについて話した後によくある質問の1つ
基本を説明するの
は
ちょっと待ってください。
日本語のすべての単語の高低アクセントを調べ
なければなり
ません。そうしないと、異質に聞こえ
ます。答えは、あなたがそうするという意味で「はい」と「いいえ」
です。
日本語で高低アクセントがオフになっているのは4音以上ですが
、良いニュースは
、数十から数十の
ルールがあることです。これは、数十の高低アクセントを自動的に知るために使用できる私のパトレオンシリーズでカバーして
います。
短い簡潔なルールのように覚えるだけで、何百もの異なる単語
が私のシリーズで最近詳細に取り上げた別のトピックは
、典型的な日本語の声と
話し方
が、典型的な
ネイティブの
英語話者のそれとどのように異なるか、そして
あなたが アニメをたくさん見たり、
日本のテレビ番組をたくさん見たりしても、高低アクセントや違いがあり、プロンがあると
いうだけでなく、いつも気づいているかもしれません。
unciationの違いですが
、声自体が少し違う
ので
、
nhkアカデミーに行ったネイティブスピーカーと非常に実用的な方法でそのトピックを分解しようと
しました。彼女にいくつかのインタビューを行い
、基本的にすべての情報を使用しました
その
特定のビデオのインタビューから、
おそらく多くの人に役立つと思います
が、私は
ここで接線をたどっているので、
ここでもう一度やり直しますこれ
は一種の追加です
私がパトレオンでカバーしているものは、あなたたちが
サインアップすることを検討することを願っていますそれはクールではありませ
んあなたの継続的なサポートに感謝します
そして私はあなたたちにすぐにまた話します
[音楽]
あなた